Okay, let me get this straight: pasta and gelato,...
...two iconic Italian foods that have beautifully collided in Germany.
Oh, right.
But before all our Italian viewers get angry at us,...
...we should explain that it was Dario's Italian grandfather...
...who started the family's ice cream obsession,...
...but it was Dario, whose invention, changed the world.
So, apart from making children cry, the dish proved popular.
Actually, popular might be an understatement.
For Dario, his invention has catapulted him to ice cream fame.
But the important thing isn't ice cream fame.
The important thing is the fun of it all.
You're telling me.
It freaked me out a little bit at the beginning of this video,...
...but I sort of want it now.